it's Ghost Rider vs Wolverine chaps and
this story is amazing check this out so
ever since the beginning of Benjamin
Percy's Ghost Rider run there's been
something a little off about Johnny
Storm not Johnny Storm Johnny Blaze
although admittedly Johnny stormed the
Human Torch becoming the Ghost Rider
sounds amazing
Johnny Blaze outside of
[Music]
sadod whose power Rivals that of cosmic
entities and forcing people to endure
all the pain they've caused over the
course of their lives something seems a
little off about him we ended up finding
out that by whatever Manner and whatever
means he literally has a demon in his
head like a physical demon in his skull
and so at the end of the last story arc
that we did where he basically came back
into contact with Wolverine we're now at
a point where Wolverine drags him into a
bar in order to exercise the demons and
so the first thing Wolverine tells
everybody is to get while the kittens
good now the funny thing here is that
there's this guy who pulls a revolver
and just yells at Wolverine for being a
mutant and I actually love this to be
honest with you guys I love this moment
because what it does is it reminds us
that in this grand scheme of Wolverine
bringing in a demonically empowered God
who needs to have a demon removed from
his head this guy is worried about the
fact that Wolverine is a mutant if only
this guy knew what was going on he would
realize that Wolverine being a mutant is
the least of his concerns so this guy
decides to pull a gun and Wolverine
helps this guy understand his place in a
bigger picture by grabbing an eight ball
and hitting him in the face with it well
he literally just throws it it just hits
him in the face and then he comes
running up on him like a bat out of hell
pops his claws and like punches him
through a wall and that's when this guy
realizes it's in his best interest to
leave and he does and so Johnny Blaze is
just like freaking out on this pool
table and so you get this really amazing
moment right because for those people
who are not familiar with the Wolverine
Ghost Rider relationship they're not the
best of friends but they're not the
worst of enemies Wolverine as a
character in Marvel Comics this guy's
been down pretty much every path this
guy's fought demons this guy's fought
monsters from outer space he's fought
alongside the X-Men he's fought demigods
this guy's basically fought it off but
some of the best stories in Marvel
Comics with Wolverine are the stories
where it was him in Ghost Rider in like
the midnight Sons fighting like this
dark Mythic demonic aspect of Marvel
Comics because you never really see
Wolverine do that but as a guy who's
seemingly seen and done it all he
literally drinks a beer from himself
gives a beard to Johnny Blaze and then
pour some alcohol over one of his claws
and he's like okay this is gonna hurt
buddy uh I'm gonna do my best with this
back alley surgery fires a purifier but
honestly I don't even know if you're
gonna live through this but if you do
die you'll still be better off than
where you are right now because this
thing is just like emerging from his
head and so Wolverine just uses his
claws and starts cutting away at this
just demon thing that's sticking out of
Johnny Blaze's head the whole time
Johnny Blaze is just screaming right ah
he's just like screaming and carrying on
but it's one of those weird things
because Wolverine says okay look man
like I've known you for a long time
you've always been sick but this is
something else man there's a whole
different thing going on here now what
makes this situation even more
complicated this just most insane level
of exorcism that I've ever seen in my
life which I'll be honest with you guys
man if we got this in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it would be dope I'll
give you one of the coolest things ever
right like this is one of those those
scenes that people would upload on
YouTube and it would just blow up often
just get millions of views but like this
back alley exorcism what Johnny Blaze
says is that Logan literally has to kill
him because it's not just some demonic
entity that's rolling around in his head
it's infesting the entire part of his
body like leaving his skull crawling
down his throat and then exits out of
his belly button this is dark man and
then like it immediately takes off and
then it basically attaches itself to
like another guy now here's the thing
it's not just one demonic entity that's
infected Johnny Blaze it's a whole host
of them disguise quite literally Legion
right for we are mini that's what this
is just all these demonic beings that
have basically infected him and so once
one of them attaches themselves to this
guy who would basically just drank
himself unconscious it goes and grabs a
circular saw right like a buzz saw and
then throws it at Wolverine so Wolverine
of course goes running over there and
just cuts this guy's legs off and then
in turn it basically starts appealing to
the Ghost Rider Persona because one of
the things to know here is that when it
comes to Johnny Blaze Johnny Blaze as a
normal guy you could kill him any number
of ways you can just shoot him in the
head and like that's the end of him but
the Ghost Rider Persona is a whole
different beast and so what he says is
like I don't need Johnny Blaze here I
need the Ghost Rider because this
exorcism thing this just back alley
exorcism is way more than I can
certainly just handle on my own I can
cut and hack and slash you know demonic
tentacles all day long but the truth
about it is in order to actually get in
there and to burn these demons out it
has to be done by the Ghost Rider and so
literally he just starts appealing to
him now the Ghost Rider only ever
manifests when an innocent life is in
danger specifically with regards to a
person committing a nefarious act the
Ghost Rider won't usually manifest if
like a kid's ball goes out into the
street the kid goes chasing it like a
car is coming down the road at that
point like the kid would probably just
die right Ghost Rider doesn't usually
manifest that way the Ghost Rider does
manifest if there's some serial killer
on the prowl and he's got a victim in
the trunk of his car and so when
Wolverine tells the Ghost Rider you need
to manifest because Johnny Blaze is
going to die from the this demonic
possession that will kill him the Ghost
Rider jumps in now here's the funny
thing about this Wolverine in and of
himself even just using his claws
despite his healing factor and his claws
being unbreakable isn't enough and Ghost
Rider himself isn't necessarily enough
but Ghost Rider realizes that Wolverine
can be enough with the right kind of
modification if you understand what I'm
saying so Ghost Rider grabs Wolverine
and then imbues his claws with the power
of Hellfire literally Wolverine becomes
a Hellfire powered demon now here's the
reason why that matters in Marvel Comics
you've got all kinds of different magic
and mysticism and all sorts of different
things Hellfire is a kind of fire that
can eradicate anything outside of
exceedingly high level Cosmic entities
Galactus eternity Infinity things like
that pretty much everybody will fall
before the power of Hellfire now off the
top of my head I cannot speak to whether
or not Thanos has like fought the Ghost
Rider and been exposed to Hellfire so I
don't know if Thanos is like his normal
form for example could be killed by
Hellfire
actually no way now that I think about
it no it was Cosmic Ghost Rider I forgot
about that okay there's differences here
there's differences here but for those
of you guys who remember that story
you'll find a link to a pinned in the
comments section of the video that story
was dope basically like Frank Castle The
Punisher became the new Ghost Rider and
then he becomes a Herald of Galactus so
it gets the power Cosmic so it's like
the Ghost Rider with the power Cosmic
then he fights Thanos and like he tries
to use his pen and stair and it doesn't
work right the the like Thanos is like
that's not gonna work on me so Ghost
Rider just like incinerates him all the
way down to his skull that was dope okay
so yes Ghost Rider the Hellfire works on
on Thanos I don't know if it's really
the same thing though because I feel
like it's a combination of Hellfire and
the power Cosmic I don't know you guys
be the judge in the comments section you
guys tell me which one it is but The
Incredible Hulk yep we saw that in World
War Hulk when he went toe-to-toe with
the Ghost Rider and got wrecked so I
mean it's one of these things where the
Ghost Rider's pretty powerful it's kind
of nuts but Wolverine having his claws
bonded to Hellfire is enough that he's
able to rip out this core demon and
completely and totally incinerate it and
so with this deed being done Johnny
Blaze is now cured of the demon that
infects him which of course allows him
and Wolverine to essentially leave but
one piece of this demon remains behind
and still keeps itself attached to some
guy who is passed out in the bark but
this was an amazing story let me know
what you guys think down in the comment
section I know it's short but it's
really good let me know what you guys
think down in the comment section thank
you all for watching and I'll catch you
all later
peace
foreign
[Music]